- Colorado, leaves, blue.
- K, great, great, lovely.
Let's do this.
(hip hop music)
♪ I look at fabric, I respect 'em ♪
♪ Rejecting anything not
represent the spectrum ♪
♪ Call it blue, that be Cyan ♪
♪ And I'm trying to sigh ♪
♪ Because the blue in the
sky and it catch my eye ♪
♪ Deep blue, maybe light ♪
♪ Feeling kind of Royal ♪
♪ So many varieties ♪
♪ You know, I'm gonna spoil, ♪
♪ Like I'm on the water ♪
♪ Why, cause it's wavy? ♪
♪ No, cause it's blue ♪
♪ So, you know, that's the Navy ♪
♪ That's a blue pun ♪
♪ I'm gonna do one ♪
♪ So many leaves, gotta choose some ♪
♪ Look at this, this a lesson in leaves ♪
♪ I'll let you learn ♪
♪ I don't know these, but
that's definitely a fern ♪
♪ It's got the fronds, it
unfurls with the seed pods ♪
♪ These ones, maple leaf, yeah real odd ♪
♪ I know you're looking at like me like ♪
♪ Before he said this was a maple ♪
♪ But this is Sycamore probably ♪
♪ I don't even know ♪
♪ I say there's two colors on the leaves ♪
♪ That's variegated, ♪
♪ you know, usually you
got the green and white ♪
♪ and then where are we now? ♪
♪ We're checking it, right? ♪
♪ No need for the map. ♪
♪ We never need to guess. ♪
♪ We're in Colorado. ♪
♪ Rejecting the GPS ♪
♪ rapping for the things
painted with the ink. ♪
♪ I like the little pennies on your hat ♪
♪ What do you think? ♪ ♪
Looking like a buffalo. ♪
♪ Is that a nickel or a dollar? ♪
♪ I can't tell, got the
mask and the little collar ♪
♪ I'm trying to say this. ♪
♪ Look at the hand. ♪
♪ It's like, kind of thick elastic band ♪
♪ but this you need to get the
beads and I've seen it before ♪
♪ the blue upon the hammered
metal I can call it azure ♪
♪ I implore everybody, paint like this ♪
♪ It's like a little ripple over there. ♪
♪ Please sis, please, Chris stop. ♪
That's the end of that.
There we go.
There you go.
(laughing)
For you guys.
You have no idea what's going on.
Okay cool.
(hiphop music)
♪ First one, let me rap for you. ♪
♪ I try it. ♪
♪ Is it a kayak or is it canoe? ♪
♪ I don't know. ♪
♪ Front to back. ♪
♪ That's a palindrome, I'm
sitting in the kayak like, ♪
♪ I am King on the
throne. ♪ ♪ Full grown. ♪
♪ This one's smaller than the rest ♪
♪ Either, Or, I put it to the test. ♪
♪ That's an oar pun. ♪
♪ Let me check out it now. ♪
♪ Coming from Arkansas,
calling it a Brown ♪
♪ Is your name Jenny? ♪
♪ See it in the signature. ♪
♪ A fish in the river. ♪
♪ Yeah. You know, I'm pretty sure. ♪
♪ What do you think? ♪
♪ 15 out of 15. ♪
♪ That's the name of print. ♪
♪ It's looking real nifty. ♪
♪ That's not 'fin'. ♪
♪ Like the end, my friend;
a broad tailed hummingbird ♪
♪ I intend to sip upon the
nectar from every flower. ♪
♪ If I was a bird ♪
♪ I would have it in my power
to never glower at you. ♪
♪ Not cast a beady eye,
hummingbird frequency. ♪
♪ When I'm flying by, fluttering around ♪
♪ looking for this sound ♪
♪ Ah, wise, like an owl, Screech
like Saved from the Bell. ♪
♪ 17 of 19. ♪
♪ Yes. I can tell. ♪
♪ Look at this so wide eyed,
like he's been scared. ♪
♪ And if I was over here,
he'd be spinning his head. ♪
♪ Don't hate these. ♪
♪ We'd be mateys ♪
♪ I'm a kick flip 180. ♪
♪ That's the frequency. ♪
♪ When he's turnin' all his head ♪
♪ Yes, please give me more. ♪
♪ Not rapping about the
owl degrees. ♪ ♪ Oh geez. ♪
♪ I get an earful. ♪
♪ If I call it a buck it's
a buggling book, bugling. ♪
♪ Technically that's the deer call. ♪
♪ If you see them in the
forest, they are not small. ♪
♪ They're large. ♪
♪ I'd be taking this like a
chance there, got your head ♪
♪ in the air with the
antlers, I lop them off. ♪
♪ Put them on the back of my arm chair. ♪
♪ It's in the house we stay
in. ♪ ♪ Yeah I do care. ♪
♪ And this one. ♪
♪ Ah he's so frizzly ♪
♪ He got the fluff upon his body. ♪
♪ That's a grizzly looking kind of sad. ♪
♪ He'd be like, Oh mate, I'm frustrated. ♪
♪ Cause I got a hibernate. ♪
♪ Wait, let me check this out. ♪
♪ It's a tiny little owl. ♪
♪ Where's it from? Nobody knows. ♪
♪ Nobody tells, it looks like it's ♪
♪ in the film, Harry Potter, ♪
♪ the owl that Neville Longbottom's
got I don't even know ♪
♪ what more we can do. ♪
♪ There's a little plush owl up there. ♪
♪ That's the truth. ♪
♪ Looking over everything ♪
♪ Scaring all the birds
away for NoreenArt. ♪
♪ Those the words that we say ♪
- [Narrator] If you would
like a Chris Turner hat
or face mask, they're on
sale now at goodsirLA.com.
- Macchiato,
- So macchiato,
- I was going to say passion fruit
- Passion fruit
- Leather
- Lather? Lather,
passion fruit, macchiato,
and wap, which is WAP.
♪ Take a photo like a pap. ♪
♪ I get fussy with the wet ass
pussy, calling that a WAP ♪
♪ like Ben Shapiro, Wet Ass P word ♪
♪ What's the problem? ♪
♪ Say pussy. ♪
♪ You're damn nerd. ♪
♪ I like the video, we all agree. ♪
♪ You got Megan Thee
Stallion and Cardi B. ♪
♪ Any way, getting down,
having sex with the floor ♪
♪ then Kendall Jenner, was it
walking down in the hall? ♪
♪ I don't know. ♪
♪ I'm feeling like I'm asking. ♪
♪ Get my passions rising like
the fruit with the passion ♪
♪ I'll be pashing in the corner. ♪
♪ Like a passionate kiss. ♪
♪ Got the fruit with the juice. ♪
♪ I be licking my lips. ♪
♪ I've never ate one, at
all, not had the greed ♪
♪ but usually passion fruit
only consumed the seeds ♪
♪ like a pomegranate. ♪
♪ I don't know again. ♪
♪ It's too expensive. ♪
♪ Let me think about this. ♪
♪ I'm getting pensive. ♪
♪ When I want a coffee,
where do I go? To Starbucks ♪
♪ I instruct, make a macchiato. ♪
♪ It comes out. ♪
♪ They make it upside down. ♪
♪ It's got the white milk
and then espresso brown ♪
♪ It's my favorite thing. ♪
♪ I can say I'm like, fuck
cappuccino and fuck latte ♪
♪ Macchiato, the only
drink for the fellow. ♪
♪ I like it with the caffeine. ♪
♪ Yeah, never mellow. ♪
♪ Remind me of your word. ♪
♪ Say its out again. ♪
♪ Okay. Yeah, my hearing
it kind of went. ♪
♪ I thought you said lather
like I'm having bubble baths ♪
♪ but you were like no, ♪
♪ from a cow's ass, from a cow's hide. ♪
♪ Take it to a tannery,
get a leather jacket ♪
♪ and I'm trying to see, is
that a hundred percent? ♪
♪ Is that what you needin',
offending my cameraman. ♪
♪ Cause he's a vegan. ♪
(cheering)
- [Narrator] Thanks for watching.
Please do like and subscribe
and check out another one
of my freestyle videos.
- We double offended you because
we have milk and leather so
(laughing)